Lately, we've been hearing that
unemployment is at a record low,
which is a good thing for the economy.
But I just got done looking deep into
unemployment for this video we made. And my
big takeaway is unemployment is actually,
like, not super well understood. I think
most people think of unemployment as, like,
the number of people who don't work. That's like
the rate that they give, like 3% or whatever. But
it's actually slightly more nuanced than that.
It's not everyone in the economy who can't find
a job. It's actually the number of people who
want a job, who are like out looking for a job,
who can't find a job. There are a lot of jobs
in the economy that aren't counted because they
don't, like, pay money. So like people who care
for other people, like parents or something, they
don't count in the unemployment figure. It's only
people who are out there looking for jobs that
make money. And what it doesn't capture is people
who are overqualified for their jobs, like someone
who studied like to be a pharmacist but can't
find a job in being a pharmacist, and so they,
like, teach tennis lessons or something. They're
technically employed, but they're underemployed.